there's a great book by Jean Youngblood
called expanded cinema was written in
the 70s and he said cinema reflects
mankind's historical drive to manifest
his consciousness outside of his mind in
front of his eyes so this idea of cinema
being a mirror to our subjectivity
unlike anything else in the world right
there's reality and then there's our
first person's subjective perspective on
the world right objective subjective and
documentaries you know are the news even
though the news is biased tries to show
you the objective world cinema is the
only tool I think that shows you the
subjective world
I mean maybe music does to Hugo Merton
bird was one of these film first like
scholars to talk about the power of film
back when it was called the photo play
like 1912 or something and he was the
first to say the photo play works like
the mind more than like reality it was
like the close-up reflects attention
right the flashback represents memory
the foreshadowing represents thinking of
the future right so it's interesting and
also in film you have cuts between
different scenes how come that doesn't
give us a seizure how can we can stitch
together narratives even when you're
cutting between different places and Moe
because that's how we are you know we're
doing that persistence of vision is a
human thing you know like we that's how
we stitch together reality but I
researched this even more and I found
this guy called
wrote a book called mine screen or
something like that
and he said that basically cinema is
consciousness
externalized and so consciousness meets
its own process when we watch a film I
think about that you're sitting in a
room in the dark there's a massive
screen and because it's dark you kind of
forget your body forget yourself you
don't have nothing to attend to the
grounds of them including the objective
also it's all subjective world now and
and not constrained by time and space
even so it's all mind so here you are
the screen turns on and your
consciousness is meeting a version of
its own process like you're actually
looking at a mirror of consciousness on
the button screen and the guy that
directed before stuff before sunrise
trilogies I forgot his name the director
anyway he did his documentary about
cinema in time and he said the reason
that we didn't have to learn how to
watch your movies is because we've been
doing it every night when we sleep
forever when we dream it's all mind as
well and so so all of that I think is is
wonderful because back to the feeling of
connection cinema like connecting with a
person connecting with a film is an
inter subjective experience it's
assuming the viewpoint of a character
it's not looking at the screen it's
looking into the screen and into the
character's minds and once you assume
the viewpoint of the character looking
out through the characters point of view
so assuming the viewpoint of somebody
else means becoming somebody else and
from a phenomenological perspective what
the [ __ ] is going on right you know the
Greeks talk about Chronos and Kairos so
Chronos the other film is one hour and
20 minute running time it's 24 frames
per second it's scripted there's actors
yeah sure there's an explanation in
Chronos but in Kairos from the inside in
the movie theater it's like a lived myth
bolts from the outside but true from the
inside and what happens when I assume
the viewpoint of the character and I
have an experience that may it's like a
psychedelic trip it may be objectively 2
hours long but but phenomenologically it
exists outside of
and it transformed my consciousness even
though it wasn't about me or my
biography right it was a [ __ ] another
character another story and yet
archetypal it mirrored me so I was him
but he was also me what is that you know
like what is that like from a
transpersonal perspective has anybody
ever like really thought about it like
hmm like that's an interesting
phenomenon when we watch films it's a
completely trans personal experience and
for people who overly identify who have
the diseases of over identification with
the ego as policemen from an
autobiographical perspective they could
get a lot of medicinal intervention from
watching a movie and losing themselves
in the movie there's a lot of freedom
from undergoing an experience that
doesn't happen to you at least not to
your biography like what is that so I
just I just really love it it's a drug I
enjoy